hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle un peu coup là comme ça
j'aime bien c'est nouveau ça vous avez
mort là sur la cruella et hagard alors
c'est pas mal c'est plus son avance
d'habitués de c'est pour cacher la ride
du lion
ah ouais bah allez pas caché parce qu'en
fait le même bruit n'est pas de rides du
lion dont je vous jure n'être pas du
tout ridé vous non c'est vrai le nul par
great pas terrifier je sais c'est pour
ça que je lui dis vert qu'est ce qu'elle
a fait ce week end j'ai rien et jean-luc
chez nagui
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé jean-luc dans sa douche
hbo a baissé sa troupe au travail en
pleine nuit au bouton il ya isabelle
morini-bosc aller rouler comme ça alors
ça a été avec alain gueguen et je crois
que oui je crois et et crac crac à quoi
je sais que tous les week-ends m le dit
c'est tous les samedis soirs abbas pour
dire on est un matin matin c'est ma main
lorsqu'il s'endort le soir quoi se doit
par ses esprits criminels norway
c'est un meilleur pour un toto moto
annoncé tous les matins du matin
c'est vrai c'est tous les samedis matin
mais s'étend autour de tumeurs sauf si
on est fâché mais bien longtemps de
cette heure un coq qui chante
il faut que j'aille la pécho mais je
mets ton réveil pour faire ça non je
mets mon réveil après pour dire ça me
prendre grosso modo temps donc après je
mets le réveil pour être sûr de me
réveiller après parce que vous dormez
pendant six à merci et de ramallah
grella l'eau
[Applaudissements]